So in the last slide I kind of talked about that images basically have a lot of
numerical values that we can actually be traversing around on a matrix and
a regular grid.
Now let's look at what we can do with that kind of stuff.
One of the things I want us to think about is the whole concept of
an image histogram.
An image histogram basically measures the statistics of the image.
In terms of all of the gray values that exist in that image.
So imagine if I could.
As I have created a bin which has values of 0 to 255.
And every time I will scan through this image.
And every time I'll say, come down to the first one.
I see the value of intensity is let's say 120, I will put one there.
And then I will go find another one maybe 125.
I might move around and, and
basically it starts mentioning how many pixels have a value of let's say 200?
How many pixels have a value of 100?
And that will start of kind of creating a histogram of that image and
kind of start giving you statics of that image.
And this basically is what this image's histogram looks like.
With a peak here, comes down, and closes this way.
Now interesting thing to note is there're not a lot of full 100% white values
here, and if you look at this image, you might actually see that to be true.
There's a few zeros, dark values here.
But most of the information is right in the middle.
Now of course, we don't have to do this for the entire image.
Now the things to note is that we can actually do statistics on the whole image.
We can compute the average for the entire image.
You can compute the median, or
any other kind of statistical, statistical information for that image.
The scope of this need not be the entire image.
I could just say is I want to do it for this box.
Or I want to actually, even if I could figure out how to come up with this,
just this region, what would be the statistics of this, or just the,
you know, pixels associated with that eye.
Of course, I would have to find the scope,
the range of that region to be able to do those computations in.
But that entirely depends on us.
This histogram of course is for the entire image.
But of course, in the, histograms could also be for specific ranges.
I could do one for this region, this region, this region.
And again it basically starts giving me information about what is the range of
information, of the pixel values, the intensities for that specific subpart.
It could be region-based, and of course it could be channel-based.
Now I haven't actually introduced concept of channels yet, but
that's coming soon.